[Musique]
conservateur chanson de mireille dumas
verdon la dévore jugement installée dans
les jardins des ambassadeurs aux champs
elysées balade est en train de faire mon
porte feuille vierge en diable et moi je
tiens à vous remercier car vraiment vous
avez été très gentil de nous envoyer de
si nombreuses lettres pour le donner
votre avis sur les salaires qui sont
passés au dernier conservatoire des
lâches personnes je vous rappelle notre
adresse petit conservatoire de la
chanson de mireille 107 ch de grenelle
paris 7e
tiens pas à venir elle pendant qu'elle
n'est pas là pour savoir pourquoi vous
aimez me veil
pourquoi vous aimez la femme qui se
cache derrière le professeur nicole d'un
petit lutin méconnaître secret john f
jocelyne l'adorable fait qu'ils manient
la belgique avec beaucoup de tact et de
crise plus daniel ou en perçant les
retenir et sa jeunesse
dans son cou carpenteyre 60 amende de
chanter sur
bertin mois pour tout ce qu'elle a
menées dans le tour de chant danse
l'ibère parce qu'elle est très dure avec
les mêmes et pas seulement avec
elle-même et avec les gens que la mène à
la france en personne
je trouve que les femmes
rappel était dans la bouche d'or selva
la démo vous connaîtrez le côté
fermières de mireille capter les dents
campagne et qu'elle ce qui est de ses
bureaux et de ses brebis parce qu'il
faut vous dire que mireille à des
bouteilles ce problème
ils sont des personnages auxquels on
peut parler d'accord il ya charlotte qui
allait être en vedette à ma vie à
juliette
il ya pour baiser à mardi il ya aussi
fermé jusqu'à lundi
pendant toute la semaine
enfermé dans le bureau on le trap
l'amigo on travaille beaucoup trop mais
la fin de la semaine ça m'aide
on dit ça n'est pas trop tôt quand
l'appli tant de peine de prendre un peu
de repos lorsque l'on lance sonne midi
midi au bureau plus personne
personne jusqu'à lundi s il au téléphone
matampi patron de la patronne
tout le monde est parti michel lis pas
le pech du le chez des amis
et robert se dépêche d'aller retrouver
mimi on a mis sur la porte à vis à vis
au razer de toutes sortes fermé jusqu'à
lundi tous les jours le chef comptable
me fais sans en avoir l'air un coup de
pied sous la table
si vous tapez sur les nerfs lorsqu'il me
dit une lettre en pays d'olmes plaisante
je ne sais plus où est maigre mais le
samedi matin lorsqu'un vent larsson
mehdi milly himdi ma petite mignonne
mais dont jusqu'à le dis je réponds mon
vieux bonhomme
merci merci mais pour voir votre baume
toute la semaine me suffit
non vraiment je regrette mais vous voyez
là bas mon amoureux peut-être ai-je eu
vol dans ses droits on a mis sur la
porte à vis à vis au 20h de toutes
sortes vous fermé jusqu'à lundi
oui oui attendent en attendant pour le
vendre aux spectateurs que mireille
comme tout le monde a des ennuis
maintenant et la détente elle a attendu
elle dit qu'elle a à cactus je m'en
souvenir de dessinateurs et bien mes
enfants nous allons avoir une série de
cactus parce que j'ai l'impression que
ça sorte à orly dans mademoiselle
simoneau s'il vous plaît
mademoiselle simoneau brillante vous
êtes comedian nesta et pourquoi est ce
que vous voulez faire un tour de chant
brusquement je suis passionnée par la
chanson jour jeudi de poèmes en public
dans une émission de variétés qui était
télévisée aussi j'ai trouvé merveilleux
d'être seul devant le public d'avoir
quelque chose
ah oui c'est comme ça qu'est ce que vous
pouvez parler un peu plus fort mes
enfants s'il vous plaît l'heure c'est
l'heure soyez gentils carpenteyre vous
en prie nicollin je suis très très
enjoué mesdames si vous êtes présent
huîtres et bien mademoiselle vous savez
que dans ce métier que vous voulez
affronter enrouée aphone manar le public
ne doit jamais le savoir
hall est toujours ou décupler ou le
savon c'est un esclave
qu'est ce qui vous fait croire
mademoiselle que vous pourrez réussir
dans le tour de chant est ce que vous
croyez vous le pourrez oui je crois que
je pourrais qu'est ce qui vous fait
croire ça n'est ni la volonté ni la
persévérance ni le talent ni le don il
ya autre chose encore vous savez puisque
vous êtes comédienne vous savez ce que
c'est que avoir l'oeil au théâtre n'est
ce pas et ça on l'a où on ne l'a pas
c'est une sorte de petite complicité qui
s'établit entre le public et l'artiste
est ce que vous croyez que vous avez sa
mademoiselle simoneau par moi moi je
crois par d'autres je crois plus la
ligne après la peau encore
et puis après je recroise voilà
maintenant vous parler un petit peu plus
fort ça va mieux
voyez malin l'enrouement quel personnage
auriez vous aimé être si je pouvais vous
transposez vous transposez en quelqu'un
chanteuse
comédienne j'ai l'impression que vous
ressemblez un tout petit peu à maria
casarès comme ça on nous l'a jamais dit
un peu un petit peu et comme chanteuse
qui catherine sauvage et des troupes à
mercredi moselle simoneau monsieur
l'italien venez là aussi l'italien vous
êtes à paris depuis combien de clients
quand moi c'est ça c'est l'époque à la
lettre à peu près à laquelle nous nous
sommes rencontrés c'est ça bon j'étais
en train de faire un mélange italiens et
français c'est pour ça que je bafouille
et vous savez ce que ça veut dire
bafouillé un italien
non non moi vous allez voir quand vous
essaierez chanter en français ça fera à
peu près au début ça qu'est ce que vous
faisiez avant de chanter monsieur 800
que sur un paquet de gâteaux des gâteaux
plus févier des éclairs au chocolat même
débat bah oui de ba ba demba ba oui on a
mangé aussi un item des tartelettes
si oui les tartelettes ou si vous saviez
bien fait à votre métier comment un
petit peu
j'espère que les tartes était bonne
bonjour pourquoi est ce que vous avez eu
envie de venir chanter à paris
moi j'aime j'aime beaucoup vu oui mais
ce n'est pas la seule raison
vous avez appris à chanter en italie le
classique
oui vous avez l'air d'hésiter avec un m
oui j'ai fait le conservatoire avec à
main par les plus forts luigi j'ai fait
le conservatoire avec m voilà quel âge
avez-vous 21 ans 21 ans fruit faut pas
hésiter non non moi je le dis plus mais
c'est une autre histoire
le maître robert valentie nous va vous
accompagner la wii dites moi monsieur
luigi quand vous chantez vous ne vous
occupez plus maintenant du maître non
non vous pensé au public
mais ça vous allez chanter la chanson à
la mode qui s'appelle romantique
romantique a parlé un peu plus un show
man 10 kg à la gagnante de mire festival
à rester avec petit placement
pour ce héros m'a menti quant à marion
pozzi vivait
mais la suite à notre état
tout ça est romantique à amy cadets les
nouveaux l'ère chrétienne canaux la soul
ou en dise oh oh mais frei
le sosie pas des isp il anima say to
yami encore vif à la vie kouadio
sans ritonavir air act et là comme
terreau a fait d'erreur et sony miel
mercure romane du grand crohot moxico
seul
[Musique]
et pour
[Applaudissements]
luigi pourquoi est ce que vous faites un
tout petit peu de gestes tout le temps
pourquoi c'est pas nécessaire peut-être
un on peut qu'est ce que vous dites vous
même vous maladie j'ai entendu un
murmure séjour qu'est ce que vous avez
dit sainte anne et c'est ça voilà et
qu'est-ce que vous chantez doute est ce
que vous apprenez maintenant comme je
voulais demander à chanter en français
laurine pour tout prix nous l'avons une
porte au fimu en français oui tiens ça
commence comme ça oui on écoutera la
prochaine fois merci à mercredi s'est
lui dit au revoir
castelli s'il vous plaît laissez les
vous pouvez pas marché un tout petit peu
plus vite comme un non on ne vous
comment dans ma nature
c'est dans votre nature de marcher
lentement mais il ne vous est jamais
arrivé de courir dans la vie si une fois
pas l'autobus
je vous ai prié de venir casque ali
comme auteur vous allez ce soir écouté
une de vos interprète vous l'avez vous
déjà entendu chanter oui j'ai déjà
entendu
bon là qu'après que oui qu'est ce que je
vais vous demander de bien écouter sa
façon d'interpréter et de me dire après
comment vous pensez améliorer peut-être
sur son interprétation
c'est à l'autre leur bien sûr je
m'adresse n'est ce pas mademoiselle
barbon fou merci à castelli non donnez
lui la main c'est pas comme ça venez là
et des l'avenir donnez lui la main mais
non vous n'allez pas dire et vous la
recevez en quelques heures
mon corps comme ça simplement gentiment
vous lui tendez la main sans sens
l'exagération
vous ferez une autre fois c'est gentil
bon mademoiselle simone barbier va
interpréter votre chanson de quilles et
la musique jacking qu elle est là
chacune pierre bel a donc venez la casse
terry vont me dire et après
sinon je pense que chanson bane un radin
j'annonce ma chance oui ça fera plaisir
aux auteurs alors dû philippe castelli
et jacqueline pierre les marieuses à la
sortie de la promesse par till dawn
jackass de malheurs du temps chez la
comtesse vraie leçon l'année mon mari
yeux de ces derniers les 5 à 7 10e leur
fils
10' leurs poils mais tu te prendras
fillette doit cette glu matrimoniale
la marieuse des fureteurs on la tension
très généreux n'est pas tout sous la
main heureuse ni par semaine ou pas du
tout dix voix sur des ailes racleurs que
fois que le célibat et où elles ne font
pas de porte à porte
le syndicat est plutôt contre 8 mai par
nos élèves sont très forts le bruit
petit bruit durant contre le roi de
trèfle à telle union
mais de l'avenir dans les plastiques à
la reine de coeur un des coups mais une
étape magnifique
les marieuses cph libre ont l'intention
très jeunes épaules et pas toujours la
patte heureux dit parfois même pas du
tout dit freud t elle rappelant qu en
que le sénat est tout il en se fait des
confidences saisi native de pire il faut
bien meubler les silences qui mois de
rueil magnifique on la lit belle lui les
prix tout petit je n'ai je vous aime on
ça ne l'est clash à l'église sur tes
poteaux
[Musique]
les marieuses sitafa 12 ont l'intention
très fin mais pas toujours la nature '10
parfois même pas du tout dit fonctionner
elles ratent leur coup que le célibat 10
points sur terre et la claque que le
célibat est tout
qu'est ce que vous pensez de morges et
aucune objection à faire c'est
travailler du tout à l'heure pendant la
répétition pourquoi pas la reddition il
y avait quelque chose qui n'allait pas 5
0 me tarde que le célibat et d'ouverture
c'est un seul détail que je retenais
parler plus encaissé le seul détail que
je retenais c'était que quand elle
disait à que le célibat il d'où un
regard qui ne correspondaient pas à
chose c'est à dire elle faisait un être
l avenir trop triste et montrez moi
comment il faudrait faire leur à et
maintenant elle le fait très bien avec
vient de vous pour qu'elle comprenne
bien ce que vous attendez
tatataaa merci mes enfants savidan
voilà merci sophy
comme la petite fille modèle ah merci
c'est gentil ça vous êtes vraiment comme
si vous offriez et aucun doute des défis
modernes mais je vais parler maintenant
si vous voulez bien si vous me le
permettez des malheurs de sophie
oui enfin je vais gros malheurs du monde
à l'heure où je vais trouve à l'heure
c'est qu'il ya autre chose
d'abord je suis enrhumé sas décidément
c'est une école de rue mais ça oui oui
guy mais ensuite parlé à tous les
peuples n ont pu for web ont un petit
peu plus fort oui j'ai les ennuis pour
trouver mes chansons par exemple
pourquoi pourquoi parce que j'aime bien
que les chansons raconte quelque chose
comme selon les gens enfin papa vous
parlez vite vite je suis retrouvé
beaucoup oui si je comprends bien vous
voudriez à chaque fois trouver une
chanson qui raconte un personnage à être
la petite sophie ah qu'il est arrivé
ceci ou cela voilà c'est ça et c'est
très difficile mais vous en trouvez
quand même quelques fois oui je trouve
parlez moi un petit peu de votre autre à
l'orignal de 30 me eh bien on m'a dit
que je vous ressemblez ça c'est une très
bonne chose seulement ce qui est plus
engagé a dit aman oui donc c'est gentil
et c'est vrai mais on m'a dit également
que je vous imitait alors ça c'est plus
embêtant en pro b mais deuxièmement nuit
vous étiez au berceau quand je chantais
et là comment est ce qu'on voulait
miniter aux abords je connais vos
chansons non il ya une chose que je
voudrais vous dire oui je crois qu'il
faut jamais avoir peur de l'originalité
oui je crois que quand on commence on a
tous imiter quelqu'un c'est à dire on
avait tous envie de chanter comme
kalouga oui je veux pas citer d'exemple
mais je pourrais vous en dire sur chaque
grande vedette
l'originalité vient avec la personnalité
et ça viendra pour vous êtes rafale
aurait d'ailleurs je vais vous demander
de chanter maintenant une chanson
vidalin et d'acteurs ah oui le bouquet
bloc oui
d'euros et de lilas
la maraude il a fait un bouquet pour me
parler
et c'est d'oise autre oreille en piquant
tamar or le premier souvenir
notre premier jour là fait dérouler cet
antre hui ma mère mais nous avons laissé
les amoureux
[Musique]
au fond de la plus guerrière où l'on
s'était couché on a compté
les bouquets
du joli bouquet brandir ma vais te faire
mon ami que j'aime c'est gai ce joli
bouquet
qu'il m'avait tout faire on a mis
charmant
moi on était tous les deux sur la grille
et 12 ne louche à mon coeur
une main sur ma mal j'ai vu ton et les
ciels et j'ai triché mais on est entré
chez par les portes de logo pour don
pour avis
[Musique]
les niveaux
isa la voir
les choeurs les bonnes gens je peux vous
en donner
ce bouquet ce joli bouquet blanc qu'il
m'avait te faire on me coucher évoqué ce
joli bouquet mon premier
[Musique]
merci a bientot et bientôt balade ou
malades où vous avez fait depuis la
première émission
une chanson que j'aimerais bien que vous
chantiez que vous gardez votre cache nez
en titre ac
j'ai un peu moins le trac alors je dis
nous je voudrais vous demander balade ou
poète est ce que marc chagall est
vraiment votre titre préféré
c'est pas mon peintre préféré jeu j'aime
beaucoup de peindre mais c'est parmi
ceux que j'aime ce que j'aime le plus
pourquoi avez-vous intitulé votre
chanson la jeune fille de marc chagall
alors qu'est ce qu'ils pensent que c'est
une peinture qui marque qui m'a permis
de faire la chanson enfin le j'ai vu
cette peinture avec cette jeune fille
comme ça et là et grâce à elle que j'ai
fait la chanson est acquis a fait la
musique c'est jacky de richy elle pas là
aujourd'hui
elle aime bien la chanson chantée
au grand musée d art moderne un jour
j'avais l'âme en berne
j'ai rencontré sortant d'un bar la jeune
fille de marc chagall
[Musique]
elle souriait dans l'est
il a avec la lune ses côtés
moi je suis je suis resté là jusqu'à ce
qu'on fait
me le musée je reviens tous les jours
ensuite tous les jours faire ma vie si
la jeune fille de marc chagall revenait
toujours de son bas
là où donné qu'elle est quelque part est
toujours y avait les lilas et son
sourire et son regard et droite toujours
restée là
et puis un jour n'en pouvant plus de cet
amour qui tend m'a plu je parie une lame
de rasoir que personne n'avait pu voir
et découpé la toile afin d'avoir la
belle dans ma maison
quand je l'appris pas la main je m'en
allais vers la prison est maintenant
dans la prison j'entends la voix qui dit
voyons si tu faisais mais c'est normal
la jeune fille de marc chagall il te
faut en sortant d'ici
de tes relations billets musée afin de
pouvoir être
eh oui
[Musique]
lamoureux gardien du musée
elle est merveilleuse
quand vous l'avez répéter pour la
première fois avec robert valentie nous
il y avait 2 mercredi au cours vidal 1
et puis boubers et aucun n'était
d'accord sur la chute de la chanson le
vidal à vous reprocher la facilité rené
boubers puisque lui donna n'est pas là
aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que vous pensez maintenant je
la chute dit la vérité écoute et j'avoue
que la première édition j'étais je
partage l'avis de monsieur vidal a
maintenant dans l'interprétation il a
apporté beaucoup de choses et par son
jeu de scène on aime la chanson et je
trouve qu'elle est parfaite comme ça moi
j'aime beaucoup celle de sorte que vous
trouvez que c'est maintenant sauvées par
l'interprétation
oui la suite balade ou vous même
est ce que vous trouvez la chute faible
dit il n'y avait pas d'autres chutes
possibles
il fallait qu'ils terminent avec la
jeune fille est le seul moyen de
terminer avec elle c'était de devenir
n'ai pas d'autre solution
vous croyez il ya toujours une autre
solution solidarité bien de faire des
chansons d'arrivée de pouvoir acheter la
toile merci merci boubers santini venez
vite une seconde s'il vous plaît soyez
le seul auteur à la guitare pour
aujourd'hui je voudrais m'en allais me
suces anthony l'autre jour vous m'avez
troublé en me demandant ce que c'étais
qu'une chanson commercial et je n'ai pas
su répondre
est ce que vous y avez pensé ou bien
tout petit peu qu'est ce que c'est
qu'une chanson commerciales s'il vous
plaît assez difficile je crois que
samson commercial et surtout
le choc une chanson dont la musique est
très très très facile trop facile même
et dont les mots sont très faciles à
retenir enfin les mots se répète
toujours en faisant la musique est très
facile éléments permettraient un seul
mot t on pour se retenir
la mer n'est pas commercial pour vous la
mère absolument pas à la mer de charles
trenet personne ne sait ce que c'est
c'est un très gros succès oui mais mon
avis c'est une très belle chance et bien
alors si c'est un gros succès par là
même c'est comme vous dites il semble
commerciale une très bonne chanson
commercial qui n'auraient aucun succès
que personne ne changerait jamais
vraiment moi que tu te sois un gros
succès - la route que je crois comme
vous diriez commerciales notamment un
titre anglais
non j'aime bien la brute parce que je
trouve que la musique est jolie et qu
elle se retient
l'amour vous viendra peut-être à sera
dans la vie
ne fermez votre fenêtre
que tard dans la nuit vous
et dans ses bras danser
jusqu'au matin il vous
vous emportera
ah et la main dans
demain
l'amour vous fera peut-être faire
quelques folies
laissez vous tourner la tête
l'amour
ce n'est qu'à ce prix
balala
ma
[Musique]
l'homme
on viendra côté
ce padd ans
avis ne faire
le câble
non
là
mama
voilà
[Musique]
m
lapin
pas
conte
mais battre
[Musique]
à
m
là
allah
[Musique]
m
là
[Musique]
à
la la
là
[Musique]